i'm not allowed to read the scripts  because i'm so bad at keeping secrets  for this exact reason i would want to  tell you all the secrets whenever chris  pratt and dave peterson  are there new characters in this movie  are there new characters in this movie  do you remember when oh you might not  have been there that day mm-hmm oh i  can't talk about this i can't do it  there was like some time where they  dangled my poor stun double under a  helicopter and dunked him in a lake  damn it  so at one point spider-man ends up in a  lake i'm actually very afraid of her  um in this film  what i thought was a fake script because  it was like spider-man's in space i  don't even know how to react to what tom  just said there what did i just say yeah  there'll be spider-man two and three it  won't be homecoming two and three yeah  because we knew about the second one but  not the third one  yeah well now you know now you know  sorry marvel what